the [ __ ] is that noise it does sound
like we're be here hey guys I'm Ryan
right I'm Brady Frey we're gonna check
out from the sketch comedy channel
barely productions a short sketch called
uber meets tender
yeah it's a great idea I'm gonna be
starting up more sketches and short
films on this channel been a lot of
requests for it so I figured you know
what before I start posting more
sketches I should probably get a little
bit more familiar with other channels
barely productions never seen one other
videos let's see if they are going to
make me laugh tinder changing the way we
date yes ever changing the way we get
from place to place we've combined both
say hello to under the car service for
people looking to meet that special
someone on the way to wherever step one
open the uber app and activate
if you don't like the way the driver
looks simply swipe left using ubers
ultra-convenient technology and if you
like what you see simply like the driver
when the driver you choose also chooses
you you have a match for word to
indicate that you may sit in the front
seat when you get the right match sit
back in there don't take the wheel get
ready for the most romantic evening of
your life
it's photo box uber drivers are all
certified five-star conversationalist
spree important oh yeah
I go to like all the bands our drivers
are experts in picking you up you have
amazing eyes by the way drivers always
in the perfect gentleman so I know where
you're going but where you from
Connecticut connector cut
everyone has a sixth drive but no you
can have drive six that was really funny
that was really [ __ ] funny that guy
was hilarious his subtlety and delivery
and like the casual conversation they
were having oh man is that wasn't funny
back and forth they had going on
brilliant idea it really is I thought
that it was actually going to be a
little bit different with Murray I don't
know I just was thinking that uber and
tinder they paired up but this was
infinitely better than my idea
so yeah I gotta say I'm really glad I
didn't go with your idea cuz you don't
even know what it is yeah I don't even
quite get it and we really I don't care
to know you know like I would have
interrupted you at midnight
stop brandy don't want to hear anybody
just ask me what it was yeah and I was
filled with this immediate regret of
well good thing I stopped myself exactly
exactly and that makes me respect you I
mean it's not a good thing but I prefer
it that way
it's okay it's okay it's okay
alright now it's a little too much you
like the part when they got naked do I
like the part when they got naked um no
I didn't like the part where they got
naked that's offensive to my girlfriend
I wish they threw in like a [ __ ]
scene not oh that kind of would be funny
that would have been funny you know it's
funny about this sketch is I feel like
in some way something like this might
occur in the future you think so yeah
something like oh you gotta you want to
get picked up by someone but you want
them to be cuter or something like that
you know you want to flirt with someone
right or you know meet some stranger in
a car and possibly both there'll be a
nap there'll be a nap one one day though
you know one day for sure I know you'll
probably be a driver for them know you
really yeah I mean do I have to give it
up every time well that's your choice
okay it may tip you well like a $5 tip I
was thinking like a tip like did yours
day yeah you went that far with the word
tip mine's always in the gutter I say if
they tip you well and you're like haha
penis tip inside of me really that's
where you go for be a lady be a lady was
your mom a nun cut it out
nuns can't have kids shame on your mom
forever yeah I think the driver was
definitely my favorite but I think that
the girl was disproportionately that's
what I was thinking too because the girl
was good-looking and the guy showed up
girl was hot yeah and but the guy showed
up and I was like that attractive but
then has it progressed I was like it's
some pretty funny [ __ ] he's really
charming and he seems very sincere in
his delivery too he really got the
Kimmie I I don't know if he's a regular
on the show I don't know if this is his
channel but that was some funny [ __ ]
timing was impeccable
well I've been on a few tinder dates and
I murdered a few people oh my god tinder
I can't even tender stories someone
stuck his hand down my pants like I I
said I didn't even know what to do I
said excuse me what do you think you're
dooming wait what
this guy's stuck is yeah he stuck his
hand I
he went to hug me we were saying goodbye
and instead of hugging me he sticks his
hand on the back side of my pants Oh
first time he crossed I was like oh my
no no yeah
yeah that's just a casual thing it's a
normal thing and anything I got
Veronica's number I mean I probably
would have got harassed you know I've
learned from this channel there's been
many ways I've got in Veronica there's a
new way yeah it reminds me of this on
put my hands down doing yeah I bet your
phone that's they imply that they had
sex in the car sex in the car is pretty
tough though have you ever done that
it's it's a little it's it's rough but
it's also like not the most comfortable
it's like enjoyable in the moment but
when you're done you're like so sweaty
and I have to like get myself all like
look like I just didn't have sex in my
car and the windows are all fogged up I
just wish to had a little bit more of
that realism I love how it ends with him
kicking her out of the car like sorry I
go this parts a little awkward and then
the new date shows up that's for the
Dragon Ball de I did what did he shave
his head no we like completely bow was
it cool was a weird when you like touch
his head and kiss them was it like do I
feel like I'd be like grossed out if
you're dating a bald woman or bald man
Bob woman or if I'm a bald man and a
girl touches my head I don't know I
think it was fine he had a nice shaped
head so it wasn't weird you know how you
have people and they have weird shaped
head it's like wrinkly head or it looks
like a little mountain range or like the
back of their head it's like out here
and then their neck goes like him yeah
yeah he didn't look like that no he had
a really rounded was he black no he
wasn't no you'd he had a bald white guy
he wasn't white either well was he
Pakistani
is that a race he's from Pakistan that
we're a lad and grew up I'm kidding I
know it's an Afghanistan hey guys thanks
for joining into the educational channel
called the real rejects if you're new to
it you can subscribe and become a
rejected a and you come up with a cool
saying so you guys feel special Oh once
you subscribe the rejects become a part
of the reject family well if you're part
of a family you're not really a reject
any like it could be a group of rejects
you sure but they wouldn't get along
because it'll be much Regis and get your
beat dick beatnik on with brandy prices
baseline beatnik I need go follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter I the vine
and periscope I want to give a shout out
Catrina Marie she um recently followed
us on Twitter she wanted me to do a
reaction to the Gotham season - I don't
follow the show Gotham so I don't feel
like I could really get much insight
into it so I wanted to take the time out
to say thank you for being one of the
like 20 male no 20 female followers so I
just wanted to say thank you for doing
that
I'm you look like you're also really
young so I'm sorry I can't compliment
you in any fashion I'm saying thank you
because I don't want to go to jail
because if I'm like you know Katrina
you're a young pretty lady and I
appreciate the following thank you you
could use that against me in court and
be like I was sexually harassing you
because the woman always yummy court
cases I've had to go to any court cases
I've had to go to this is why I stop
complimenting women under the age of 15
it just gets you in a lot of trouble I
know you Katrina I'll just say that
you're a lovely
how many Hurricane Katrina jokes do you
get that must be horrible oh man I had
my mind totally went to so many
different dirty things and I just can't
really know you can you can say them I
can't say them I'll go to jail you're a
girl you're having girl talk let's hear
the Hurricane Katrina joke no let's hear
the Hurricane Katrina jack oh come on
Hurricane Katrina is a laughing matter
all right videos I'm gonna get into much
trouble